grosse déception après rambouillet en
2019 mentent en 2020 et châteaux en 2021
le tour de france ne partira pas cette
année des yvelines il s'élancera de
paris la défense arena dans les hauts de
seine la surprise est d'autant plus
grande que le département avait signé
une convention en 2019 avec aso
l'organisateur du tour de france cet
accord devait faire des yvelines le
département départ de la 21e étape
jusqu'en 2023 selon nos confrères de
l'écho républicain citant le responsable
presse du tour de france cette option a
été validé par le conseil départemental
des yvelines en mettant en avant le
rapprochement yvelines et hauts de seine
le département de son côté ne s'est pas
exprimé maigre consolation si l'étape ne
partira pas des yvelines elle y passera
tout de même on devrait connaître les
détails du parcours en début d'année
prochaine en 2023 la dernière étape de
la grande boucle devrait partir du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines